thank you
[Music]
who was there or who remembers where
they were during the infamous Mike Tyson
Evander Holyfield ear bite oh [ __ ] which
is at home I was a [ __ ] kid I thought
I was too young yeah I think I was
interested when you were a kid I wasn't
even a born yet
oh yeah he wasn't even about it I'm a
Vietnamese how old are you in 1997 dude
five oh seven oh 97. okay I was I was in
Diamond Bar I remember because like it
was a big deal for my dad to finally be
like like oh we're going over to this
uncle's house so we can watch fights you
know like no Vietnamese people are gonna
be able to afford to fight by themselves
on pay-per-view right [ __ ] yeah you can
um so and you know those giant box TVs
you know those giant box TVs are like
you sound like you're agreeing but
you're not
okay kid so so we go to my uncle's spot
uh and I remember we're watching this
thing and if everybody remembers there's
a [ __ ] first bite that happens I
think in like the third round or
something oh yeah yeah everything's wild
people are like what's happening they're
all trying to explain to the kids even
though they don't know how to explain
something that's never happened before
in [ __ ] boxing history a lot of
people don't know that it happened like
once and then you know the bite yeah
they thought it was just like one time
but but then the fact that the fight
started again and then he goes through
the second time I just remember
everybody just all these Vietnamese
people in the room like whoa that was
just the craziest [ __ ] right it was wild
well Mike Tyson recently has just talked
about how biting off Evander Holyfield's
ear earned him a [ __ ] ton of money good
for him yeah is this in that isn't that
on the spread like you can bet on that
right how many bites per fight
that's a normal thing to Tibet on
probably and what round the bite happens
to so uh like I said the famous incident
took place in the third round of their
much anticipated rematch in 97 as a
result Iron Mike was disqualified from
the fight temporarily losing his boxing
license and find a whopping three
million dollars whoa wow so how did he
make a [ __ ] ton of money off you guys
the CBD gummies
the ones that look like ears yeah that's
that's a good one they were they came
out the next day we just never knew I
think he just got so famous that he made
money like way more after that fight
just even though Okay it's 3 million
that he lost but he gained like Millions
more later
just from that
totally right he said I might have made
30 mil I wish I could do a good Mike
Tyson accent how you doing let's try it
let's try it just do it don't ask just
go kid he said um I made so much off
those [ __ ] hands listen I made so
much money because I got fined three
million for that I might have made 30
million since that happened from the
bite alone for taking pictures
pretending biting [ __ ] 10 dogs
and all that [ __ ] that's not bad
so validated that was great I closed my
eyes to make sure I was like that sounds
like my test you should do cold
Impressions more dude Nick now do Nick
no no
but you're [ __ ] cook
was it like talking to yourself dude I'm
so chill now man
so he said do you know how important
that was for people white people wanting
me to bite their ear I was fined three
million dollars and I tripled that by
just playing like I'm gonna bite ears
and all that biting [ __ ] look at meet
and greets and [ __ ] yes the amount of
times apparently afterwards that people
were like paying for him to like just
just that almost like a premium culture
meme culture whoa you said white people
yeah he says defend that defend that
defend your people die on that Hill
Colleen white person that speaks for all
white people because sometimes we need
that or else he's going to speak for
white people I think he should I think
the white person's allowing him to speak
for white people and that's even lucky
lucky designated rights I could talk
about all white all right go ahead hit
us with the top three you're a model
minority right now thank you hey top
three white issues at the moment not not
now he's speaking for white people what
are the top three hardships that whites
are going through bro Chick-fil-A not
opening on Sundays that's top number one
all right [ __ ] what else we
should get Chick-fil-A
um
you got anything
parents have a bad stereotype I gotta
read more white materials people think
a short haircut you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you might be nice that's true no
one's naming uh white people caring
anymore yeah oh that's true yeah that's
not a popular parent names are are
dropping you know what I mean I think
that's for the best yeah okay really
sorry as as the authority I retract that
statement
okay so you got you got two more to go
uh I gotta do some research on the
whites I got these numbers you live in
Pasadena bro nobody to dog sit for you
yeah that's a problem that's a problem
but I feel like all Races could feel
that you know what I mean yeah the
people in Lucifer I'm an inclusive man
no there it is Dick not everybody do you
think um so you know Mike Tyson had
money problems too right like he would
you know bankrupt yeah and that was
I think that was after it said I think
2008 because oh yeah yeah so he did make
a lot of money from that you know brand
2003
yeah he literally filed for bankruptcy
because of mismanagement of his money in
2003. so then would that have Matt oh
well I guess he made a lot of money now
from like his Persona today but like
arguably even though he's saying he made
a lot of money from the bite he ended up
bankrupt after that so after he uh was
doing things like [ __ ] making money
off the bite and all this random [ __ ]
like that he ended up getting his uh
license reinstated uh and then
continuing obviously to have a [ __ ]
phenomenal career making millions along
the way just off of Regular fighting
again but not losing though yeah he did
lose some pretty and then in 2003 when
he filed bankruptcy because of
mismanagement he just threw his
personalities Charisma the notoriety of
everything he is he was able to still
make money again largely like Nick said
from his legal marijuana business which
remarkably happens to sell THC Edibles
in the shape of Evander Holyfield's ear
those are the best
I've never tried them but dude could you
make a gummy with your ears probably
Nick's Ear Gum nobody would buy them
then you get sued by Tyson not dude you
should just make it because they're hard
right you should just come out with corn
nuts that are like oh dude corn nuts or
Nikki or pop because they're mad hard
you know touch the other one
does that hurt nah can I crack it no no
I could do this though nah okay no you
gotta go chest chest chest hurt get him
in the chest see that doesn't even hurt
bar because you get him in the chest get
him in the chest I'm gonna motorboat his
tits dude
go lower go lower go lower part of
stomach stomach stomach
yeah okay
[Laughter]
are you entertained now boys
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we need that under the desk cam oh man
crotch shots at all times but yeah
that's what I'm saying is like it's like
if it sounds funny to be like hey I made
a lot of money doing this but then we
still know that you got bankrupt a
couple years after so even if you didn't
isn't that the same weird flat yeah oh
no coming back with the [ __ ] Evander
Holyfield THC gummies is pretty crazy
that is true yeah like obviously we're
impressed by Mike Tyson's like boxing
career you know but I feel like I'm more
impressed with what he's done afterwards
me too yeah just like a modern day
philosopher yeah yeah and like what he's
built and like he's kind of resurgence
has been really [ __ ] cool especially
the video of him falling off the
hoverboard have you guys seen that yes
yeah dude I felt it it hurts my heart
but it's funny but it's in the house
right yeah it's in the house yeah dude
and he falls off the hoverboard I'm like
oh oh or even him showing up in it man
yeah dude that's so Random what's in
this movie I wish he was in a better hit
man though they met Force pretty good
hey man Floyd was not that good is it
really really good
I don't want you to fall
his lap
oh damn that's a bad one and they're
playing with the news he just look like
he has more gravity than the average
person
he's dead the rules of gravity apply
differently for him he's like in the
equations like times two times two damn
he looks dead he's a thick boy dude
recently uh there were photos of him
going around because he was in a
wheelchair at an airport so people
started getting all concerned about him
and [ __ ] like that oh yeah what was that
about he explained he said uh he said
quote I have sciatica every now and then
it flares up when it flares up I can't
even talk thank God it's the only health
problem I have I'm Splendid now but he
also says things like you know we're all
gonna die one day of course then when I
look in the mirror I see those little
spots on my face I say wow that means my
expiration date is coming close really
soon when you put money in your bank and
you get a check every week and you can
live for the rest of your life is that
security that means you won't catch a
disease you can't get hit by a car you
can't jump off a bridge I don't know is
that security can money security you
from that so he's definitely in this
there's your philosopher that you love
hey you know what's you know it's tight
though to be to be really fair even
though it says mismanagement of funds he
gave a lot of money and [ __ ] to people
that were down with him that's that was
part of the mismanagement but that's
pretty [ __ ] cool right like he gave
people a lot of like it could have been
worse he took selfish it's like MC
Hammer you know like MC Hammer [ __ ]
went broke because he had a staff of
like hundreds of his homies it's like
that's pretty cool to chalk it up as
like just mismanagement like officially
is like yeah it is but he also took care
of people he just needed a financial
advisor on staff probably he just needed
better friends with management abilities
it would also be scary to be his
financial manager though yeah I can't
buy that
like you can't buy another tiger dude
[Laughter]
that's why it'd be dope if his financial
his his financial manager was a better
boxer it was a Vander it's a Vander dude
he's like trust me Michael we're gonna
do this ear gummy thing that's gonna
work it's gonna sell like hotcakes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign